kind of a strange offseason for the
baltimore ravens defending division
champions but they're kind of the
afterthought in the afc north
everybody's on the browns everybody's
been talking about the steelers the
ravens meanwhile go about the business
of transforming the team around lamar
jackson and big cat they have been
giving off this vibe that it's going to
be a run-based offense i'm not so sure
about that and i think they may be
trying to set some people up for this
idea that they're going to run run run i
think we're going to see lamar jackson
unleashed as a passer this year
especially as teams crowd the line of
scrimmage and we've seen this off season
offensively what they're doing now they
can't sign free agents at receiver
because nobody believes they're going to
actually throw the ball so they had to
draft some guys but i think we're going
to see more balance offensively and mark
ingram is going to join that effort to
bang it between the tackles i think
that's going to draw guys to the line of
scrimmage and give lamar jackson a
chance to show us what he can do as a
quarterback but that's really the big
challenge developing lamar jackson into
the guy that he was at louisville if he
ever becomes that guy at baltimore this
is going to be a team that is competing
for super bowl appearances every season
yeah i like what they did in the draft i
think hollywood brown was uh the best
wide receiver in the draft they're
trying to build around that mouse miles
boykin also an underrated guy i thought
the interesting thing that the ravens
did this off season they let some guys
walk they let some pass rushing walk and
they instead are trying to build it up a
little bit in the secondary basically
the old formula of either you need a
great pass rush and an
average secondary or an elite secondary
and the pass rush will get home so i
think bringing in earl thomas over eric
weddle that's an upgrade that's no knock
on eric weddle but i like what they did
there and they didn't panic they didn't
go crazy and that's really what the
ravens mo is they are an organization
that has a mission they don't panic they
don't go you know nuts in free agency
they don't try to get the splashiest guy
i think they always build the team the
right way and i've always been impressed
with it it all comes down to lamar
jackson though with all that said this
is the off season can't be graded until
we find out what lamar jackson has done
to progress as a passer in the nfl
that's it because you can assign all you
want you can bring everyone all you want
in there but if lamar jackson can't at
least keep defenses honest because
there's now the books out on them you
saw the chargers game he was phenomenal
in la in that first matchup then they
play them this in the playoffs second
look the first team to get a second look
and the chargers win that game so lamar
jackson's growth is everything
especially considering the fact that
he's obviously on the rookie year rookie
contract and you can build around
something like that that's kind of the
the blueprint so to speak for the nfl so
wherever lamar jackson goes that's where
the baltimore ravens go yeah take full
advantage of the next few years spend
the money elsewhere before you have to
pay lamar jackson and defensively you
know they just kind of shrug the way the
steelers of the 90s did when star
players walk away in free agency they
won't overpay to keep them see you later
cj mosley they lost ultimately four key
players on defense terrell suggs a guy
we never thought would play for another
team he moves on eric weddle moves on
zadaria smith signs with the packers but
then they go out and they spend big
money on earl thomas i mean this is a
guy who's broken the same leg twice
there were concerns about what he would
be worth on the open market they came
out of nowhere they shocked everyone
with the deal they gave to earl thomas
but they believe in him
and i i i just i this team you know
because i always say
it's better to have low expectations
it's better to be a team that's off the
radar screen because then your guys
don't get swollen heads about everybody
saying how great they're going to be and
they can be a little bit salty about the
fact that they're not saying how great
they're going to be and of all the teams
in the afc north the ravens i think are
set up perfectly for that because it has
been all brown steelers browns steelers
brown steelers meanwhile the ravens
reigning division champions john
harbaugh signing the contract to stay
with the team when it could have been a
lame duck year for him and he markets
himself to go somewhere else next year
it's worked out very well for the
baltimore ravens this offseason and and
nobody seems to notice that was actually
my last big point and obviously
i think what did he sign the contract
still during the season right so it's
not technically an off-season move but
having john harbaugh you know
recommitted and the contract and having
avoiding that lame duck season having
john harbaugh be a part of the team
going forward i think that's just what
the ravens do and you just can count on
the ravens to always put together a good
roster and be well coached and that is
part of it that like the off-season
moves coaching is definitely part of it
so having john harbaugh on that contract
now is a big upgrade for what could have
been a lame duck season
four-year contract was announced on
january 24th so it fits an off-season
move
yeah it's
yeah so but but now they remember they
announced late in the regular season
that they were going to do it but at the
time that was interpreted as hey maybe
if you want to trade for this guy you
know don't assume he's going to be
available if you want to sign would be
your head coach you may have to call us
and deal with us they turned that into a
four-year extension by the end of
january and harbaugh is going to stick
around for a while
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports